that's like question to you then Chris
because a lot of obviously in our
circles a lot of people we know came to
Japan or moved to Japan like based on
somewhat based on their love for anime
and that's us included so like why did
you choose to move to Japan if anime
wasn't like a big reason or any reason
yeah that's asked a lot I always feel
like guilty by coming Japan and not
knowing anime or culture yeah I I just
growing up Japan was everything to me it
was so such amazing mystical wonderful
country everything I use everything I
did every crazy was Japanese in some way
from Pokemon to Nintendo's only my first
camcorder that I often used was sharp
and Panasonic after that like I don't
cheap and always felt like a country I
wanted to try and visit and go to but
being British if you look at a map of
where Japan is whether you care we're
not going North America views though
obviously it's still pretty damn far not
that fast water yeah Japan so damn far
and so I thought I'd only go there but
then I thought about teaching English
and Japan came up as an option and it
was the only country I ever thought I'd
want to teach English in and actually
immerse myself learn about the culture
see the nutshell that's kind of it
before all that like you were already
set on like leaving the UK at one point
or absolutely always wanted to live
overseas and travel somewhere so it
would have been your second option if
you never go I was gonna ask that second
option yeah I don't know if there was a
second option idea it was kind of like
Japan or nothing okay oh wow just
Japanese culture really excitedly like
all the stuff I seen about it but I hope
I watched your first video last night I
was doing some research and the vibe you
gave off almost is like alright lads I'm
in Japan I just ended up in Japan might
[ __ ] around and stay a little bit I got
the impression I just thought he was
like a thing where you're like all right
[ __ ] it might move Japan yeah kinda like
the vibe I I had got from the video I
guess but obviously hearing that I'm
like kind of shot but then I could also
see a British person not wanting to seem
like obsessed with something because
that's uncool British cool yeah no it's
not that I mean the trouble is like
yeah most people come to Japan are
interested on the anime and stuff yeah
and I mean / doing a Japanese class at
university on the side and I was not the
only one in that class that didn't
really like I'm learning Japanese and
I'm the only one who doesn't watch anime
am I gonna work it's gonna work do you
need to know animator to live in Japan
need to be into that no I think I was
just drawn to like how the culture is
very different one of the things I
studied was cultural discourse which is
so boring I never talked about it and I
was really into cultural discourse and
language and Japan kept coming up in the
studies and that was actually one reason
I never talked about that just because
it's so boring
social discourse just like how
everything in the culture just is just
so different the way people communicate
right so indirectly and there's just so
me there's such a different mindset in
Japan that is so in common
comprehensively different to most other
countries and I started learning about
that and I really wanted to kind of
immerse myself in that yeah I mean that
I think that's definitely true
especially having moved here and lived
here for a little bit we discuss there
like a bit on like our last podcast
where we discussed Japan so what was it
that made you decide to me like YouTube
videos about Japan or was it just you
you decided to like kind of vlog your
experiences or plan that before yeah
just like you turned up and you're like
this seems like good idea